on the slip and one on the mic in
continuing in the clockwise rotation so
that we give an opportunity for the
people who have taken the trouble to
write the question on the slip one
question on the slip then on the mic
again on the slip then on the mic again
on the slip and on the
mic the question is when all believe in
one God why people fight in the name of
God and in the name of
religion the person has the question
that if all the people all the human
beings or most of them believe in one
God believe in one type of religion why
do they fight why are there so much of
in fighting rights Etc and all no
religion which I know of tell that
people should fight with each other
unnecessarily no religion says that
neither the Quran neither the Veda
neither the Bible unnecessary should not
and the Holy Quran says in number 5 vers
number 32 if anyone kills any human
being unless it be for mer M or creating
Mischief in the land it is as though you
have killed the whole of
humanity Quran does not say if you kill
a Muslim you have killed the whole of
humanity if you kill any human being
unless it be for murder or creating
Mischief in the land it is as though you
have killed the whole of humanity so no
religion teaches that people should
fight with each other unnecessarily
suppose people are trying to oppress you
then most of the religion says that you
should put that oppressor back in its
place Quran says that Surah Toba that if
the people try to drive you out of your
house out of your faith out of your land
then you can fight them for self-defense
even the G the whole bhagwat Gita it is
known as the nectar of The Vedas Lord
Krishna he is giving advice to Arjun
that see you fight for the truth even if
the opposite people are
relatives don't stop if they the wrong
you fight the Quran says in is 17:81
that when truth is against falsehood
falsehood perishes for falsehood is by
its nature bound to perish the Quran is
a healing and mercy for those who
believe it was revealed in stages but
for those who are unbelievers it's
nothing but loss after loss so basically
no religion tells you to fight unless in
self-defense even the police kills the
robber in self-defense
kills the
criminal but normally under normal
circumstances people should not fight
but yet I do know that people fight why
is the big question you know what the
reason the reason is people fight for
power for material things the politician
he wants vote what does he do he
instigates a
r a right and then you get marginalized
and then Hindus vote Hindu Muslim vote
Muslim politicians
if a builder wants a land you can't
acquire the land because there are
thousand Huts there what does he do he
instigates a RI on the base of
religion the Huts are burned down and
then he builds a big building on that
land for money so these people for power
for money for material requirements
these people they instigate the rights
otherwise the common Hindu the common
Muslim alhamdulillah we love each
other we love a non-muslim brother
Bombay if you know Bombay even during
partition there was not such a right as
we had a couple of years ago engineered
by whom politicians politicians
engineered it all because for power for
material desire otherwise no religion
says that you should fight with one
another we do know we have similarities
we agree with that we have differences
also but a poli
on front of everyone you say ra Allah
front of it and behind it goes an
Engineers rats see we don't believe in
pseudo
secularism if suppose two people are
there one person is saying 2+ 2 is equal
to 4 the other person is saying 2 plus 2
equal to 5 that does not mean oh he such
a good man 2+ 2 also equal to 4 2 plus 2
also equal to 5 I am a very DB secular
person what secular
hypocrisy I should have the gut to say
see what you're saying 2 plus 2 equal to
4 is right what you're saying 2 plus 2
is five is wrong but I will not fight
with you I will tell you the truth I
will not fight with you same the Quran
says inah chapter 109 verse number
1-6 say to those who reject faith I will
not worship what you worship nor will
you worship what I worship I will not be
worship Shing that which you want me to
worship nor will you worship what I
worship to you is your way to me is
mine to your your religion to me is mine
I will present the truth to him don't do
idol worship don't have wrong concept of
God yet if you
have to use your way to me is mine the
Holy Quran says inak 2 vers number
256 there is no compulsion religion
truth stands out clear from error if you
hold the hand of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
he will take you from Darkness to light
if you hold the hand of the evil one the
devil he will take you from light to
Darkness the choice is yours but no
religion say that you should fight with
each other unnecessarily hope the answer
the
[Applause]
question my name is suil kutar official
photographer all India Radio viid bti
Service and Bombay D dasan KRA I have
visited holy country of Islam that is
Saudi Arabia three times and spent spend
nearly 4 years in Saudi Arabia and watch
Islam from closer distance now Dr Jain
my question is there is a Muslim blind
person his one ey is replaced by ey
donated by Hindu person his kidney one
kidney is replaced by kidney donated by
Christian person and his heart is
replaced by heart donated by par gentl
such a Muslim person will be allowed to
perform prayers in the Moss
[Applause]
the brother has a
question that he had been to Saudi
Arabia and one person is eyes from a
Hindu or heart from a Christian and
kidney from so and so various things so
having eye from another religion heart
from another religion can you offer
Salah in the mosque the answer is
brother according to Islam every human
being is born as a Muslim every heart is
a Muslim every kidney is a Muslim every
eye is a Muslim
what is the meaning of Muslim Muslim is
the person who submits a will to Allah
subhana tala every heart submits will to
Allah subhana tala I'm talking about the
organic heart organic heart organic
heart it pumps blood the heart of the
Christian pump's blood the heart of a
Muslim pump's blood the heart of a Hindu
pump's blood the heart is a Muslim
talking about the organic heart I the
organic eye is a Muslim but you see
wrong things I'm sorry I'm not telling
you you me the human being sees wrong
thing so human being is to blame but the
ey sees the eyes following the will of
Allah subhana wa tala the kidney it's
doing its job it's purifying it's a
Muslim so whether heart taken from a
person who's born in a Hindu family or
Christian family every heart is a Muslim
every eye is a Muslim every kidney is a
Muslim he will be very well allowed to
play a mosque but even if a non-muslim
wants to come to the mosque he's most
welcome
our beloved prophet he had discussions
about concept of God time didn't permit
me the revelation of surlas the touch
Stone the Touchstone of theology which I
gave to everyone was revealed when when
he was having a discussion with the
Christians in the mosque and they asked
him who is Allah what can you think the
Quran says we convert all the trees into
pens all the ocean into ink what will he
say Rahman what answer can he give the
direct re came tell
them
Allah Allah
ET he begs not know the
begotten there's nothing like
him next question from the slip is from
STI Malik she's an engineer as you
mentioned in your talk that Hindus say
Sun Moon snake and monkey is God
basically it's not like that we Hindus
don't believe that the above mentioned
things are God but we believe that God
is everywhere God is in each and
everything God is
in quote God is in air in fire does
Islam believe the same if not then why
what's wrong in
this the question for was that they
believe that the moon the Sun the tree
there and God but God is present
everywhere since God is present
everywhere therefore we worship it what
does Islam believe see the Holy Quran
says that wherever you turn your face
you'll find Allah subhana wa tala Allah
is everywhere but what does it mean are
you talking Allah is present physically
when Quran says Allah is everywhere do
you me to say physical my question is
what do you mean Allah is everywhere is
it physical
if physical if you believe Allah is
physical then you should be able to see
it no I can see Allah subhana wa tala
it's not physical the knowledge of Allah
is
everywhere the knowledge of Allah is
everywhere Allah has power over all
things but physically he's not
everywhere therefore the Quran gives the
logic in Sur 42 verse number
11 sh there's nothing unto him nothing
like whatever unto him so I'm telling
you the moment you worship the sun do
you mean to say God is only there
nowhere
else even if I agree with you you say
God is everywhere s of argument I agree
with you but then you're worshiping only
small part of God the tree very small in
the full Universe
spec that means indirectly you are
saying all God is so small only in the
tree only in the
snake so therefore if you have to
worship worship the true God Almighty
even though knowledge is present
everywhere he is present everywhere not
in the physical form hope the answer the
question asalamu Alum Dr brother Zakir
naak my question is regarding the form
of Allah Surah number 39 zumar verse
67 the translation says that and on the
day of Resurrection the whole of the
earth will be grasped by his hand and
the heavens will be rolled up in his
right hand the there is also an Hadith
in support of this sah bukari volume 6
Hadith number
336 can we just imagine some form of
Allah ask a question that Sur Al it says
she's correct Quran does say that that
the day of judgment Resurrection Allah
subhana wa ta'ala will hold all the
creation and various verses in the Quran
Etc but if you heard my talk sister I
gave you the key word the key the key to
this concept is for
42 verse number 11 which
says there is nothing whatever like him
so if Quran says Allah has hands people
ask me that Quran say Allah holds the
sky what do you mean holds like
that if I say I'm holding my family
together do you mean to say 24 hours I'm
with my wife and my
child I'm not holding my wife and child
always yet I'm holding them but not
holding them like that these are words
used and whenever as I said if Quran
Allah sees and hears you oh that Allah
is he like us he hears how he he Allah
Allah knows he has a hand but not like
yours and mine five fingers with nail
and with this not like that he has hand
yes he has hand how he has a
hand there is nothing like him how will
he do it allaham he will do it for sure
Quran says he hold the right hand he
will hold it in the right hand how he
hold it I don't know on the day of
judgment inshallah you and I will
witness
that the next question from the
slip asalam alikum brother Zakir as
Muslims we believe that Allah subhana
ta'ala is
n we cannot attribute any form or gender
to him why then when we speak of
almighty God or as written in the Holy
Quran Allah is always referred to as he
a
sister the sister asked a very good
question and this question had troubled
me for several
years and she asked the question Allah
is new he has got no gender so why is
written as ha as he and this question
asked to various people you know in
India and other Scholars but never got a
satisfactory reply then I myself did a
little research and then I checked it up
with the experts that when I learned
Arabic the grammar
the Arabic grammar has got only two
genders male and
female English language three gender
male female neutal so if we translate
haa into English it can be translated as
he or as it either he or it same as here
if you translate into English it can be
translated as she or it that's Arabic
language two genders English language
three genders so who if you translate
you can translate he or it he as
it
so in English it will say Allah subhana
wa ta'ala is beyond any
gender so why have used he some people
may say that if
ha means he and it and he means she and
it both means it so why did Allah use
who and not here because Quran
says say he's
Allah when I learned in grammar in
Arabic grammar I was told that in the
Arabic grammar there are certain rules
and criterias for feminine
gender feminine gender first if it is
feminine in nature like
mother it becomes a feminine
gender second rule if it ends with the
th it is feminine gender like mirat fan
ending with the it become feminine
gender Allah subhana wa T ta'ala is not
a female so it can't be feminine
it is not ending with the is it ending
with the no you can't be feminine third
is it should end with then becomes
feminine Allah doesn't end with B so it
can't become feminine and another one is
that pairs of the body toos like eyes
feminine y hands feminine Allah
is say Allah one only it's not fair so
therefore in defection in default since
it can't be used as he are it that she
it Allah uses who are it otherwise Allah
subhah wa ta'ala has got no gender at
allam Al brother my name is Ali Hussein
now in your talk you have mentioned that
and even in your earlier talks which
I've heard you have mentioned that Jesus
in Bible is nowhere claiming Divinity
now I had gone through a booklet which
was Pro propagating Christianity and
implying that all the sufferings are uh
healed by Jesus peace be upon him and uh
it gave the reference that Jesus is
saying I am the Lord who heals you and
the reference was from Exodus chapter
number 15 verse number 26 and even it
went further saying that in 1 John
chapter number 1 verse number 7 the
blood of Jesus his son cleanses us from
all sins now my emphasis on the first
reference where he's saying that I am
the Lord who heals you now doesn't this
imply or doesn't this indicate that
Jesus is claiming divinity
brother is quoting Exodus chapter number
15 ver number 26 verse 26 and saying
Jesus said that I healed you brother
Exodus is a part of the Old Testament
Old Testament Jesus Christ never spoke
in Exodus never I said in my talk
there's not a single unequivocal
statement in the whole Bible where Jesus
peace be upon him himself says that is
God worship
me this is the Bible I have got by the
Christians King James verion everything
about Jesus Christ spoke is in red you
shake it up this will never be in
red it is not the words of Jesus it word
of somebody
else and even if I agree with you for
sake of argument that Jesus did
say that he heals and the Quran does
agree with that and I said in my talk we
believe that he gave life to the Dead
with God's permission he healed those
born and blind with God's permission so
I've got no objection in agreeing that
Jesus Christ peace be upon him did heal
the people it's our faith even we
believe in it but whatever he did as the
Bible says in the gospel of Matthew
chapter number 12 verse number 28 he
cast out Devil by the spirit of God
Gospel of Luke chapter number 11 verse
number 20 with the Finger of God he cast
out
Devils he did everything which bore
witness of the father so I've got no
objection and agreeing that Jesus did do
Miracle but regarding Exodus it's not
the word of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him even if it is I've got no objection
because whatever Miracles he did Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said that this
is done by Allah subhana wa tala and
again Jesus Christ peace be upon him
said in the gospel of Matthew chapter
number 24 verse number 24 for there
shall arise many false Christ and false
prophets and if it were possible they
shall deceive the very elect Miracle is
not the test Jesus Christ PE me upon
said it's mentioned in the gospel of
Matthew chapter number 11 verse number
11 of those that born of a woman the
greatest person is John the Baptist
those that are born of a woman the
greatest person is John the Baptist that
means he was greater even than Jesus
peace be upon him because Jesus was born
to Mother Mary so amongst all born of a
woman the greatest is John the Baptist
According To Jesus peace be upon him
which Miracle did he do not a single
therefore Miracle is not the criteria to
make him God of nationalist
we thank Allah subhana tala for making
this program possible on behalf of the
Islamic Research Foundation I thank all
our guests including the press for
attending the program we also appreciate
and thank all the persons involved in
the organizing and recording of this
event
[Music]
sh in
in